it's a new week and that means it's time
for new releases do you guys remember
lich them battle mage came out on pc
last year well it's casting its magic on
ps4 and Xbox one this week Kevin van ORD
praised the ability to customize your
character to the sorcerer of your fairy
dreams with eight main sigils from which
to craft thousands of spells of no mana
or cool down you're a mean orange and
green spell casting machine and although
the world can feel linear and there's a
lot of similar enemies if you ever
wanted to roll pure magic this might be
the game for you which Tim battle mage
comes out on consoles on the
twenty-second Republic is a 5 episode
saga where you're helping a lady named
hope sneak around a secret totalitarian
nation and hacking into their network to
help her escape every episode introduces
new enemies environments puzzles and
somatic elements in a game that
developers say is heavily inspired by
classic 32-bit survival horror and
stealth action games if nothing else
you'll certainly enjoy the voice-over
talents of jennifer hale david hayter
and Dwight Schultz first episode
launches on the 22nd um how have we not
talked about TrackMania turbo yet game
looks sick player can race on over 200
different tracks across four different
locations there's various modes
including double driver that lets you
share the driving with a friend as if
you were like a student driver there's
split-screen multiplayer mode to have up
to four players and the beloved track
editor return so you can make those
insane levels that you've always wanted
yeah this looks amazing go get it it's
out on the 22nd on pc ps4 and xbox one
Bethesda's announced trio of fallout 4
DLC packs including one called atomic
rot in at Omicron the mysterious
mechanists has released a horde of evil
robots into the Commonwealth including
the devious Robo brain hunt them down
and harvest their parts to build and mod
your own custom robot companion you can
choose from hundreds of mods and you can
mix their limbs and
our abilities and weapons such as the
all-new lightning chain gun even
customize their paint schemes and choose
their voices at Omicron is designed for
characters that are level 15 or higher
you're basically making a mechanical
frankenstein of your choosing please be
careful the DLC pack will cost about 10
bucks and it's included in the fallout 4
season pass day of the tentacle also
known as maniac mansion 2 day of the
tentacle is from 1993 which makes it the
same age as miranda cosgrove from icarly
yeah that's an unnecessary fact moving
on we're finally getting a remastered
version to ps4 the game's plot follows
Bernard and his friends hoagie and
Laverne as they attempt to stop an evil
purple tentacle a sentient disembodied
tentacle from taking over the world
that's the 22nd Hyrule warriors is
making the 3ds transition it's the same
hack and slash action game you know from
Wii U but they've added a bit more love
for the portable system you get medley
from wind waker as a new character
she'll be free on Wii U and 3ds and
she'll be available when the legends
first DLC pack releases word of warning
doesn't work well on the original 3ds
you're going to want one of the newer
ones if you want this game to play the
way it should be played that's out on
March 25th gotta mention this heavy
metal inspired combat puzzle game with
gore galore the gorgeous detailed pixel
art lends itself so well to the brutally
vivid enemies you slay with your
massively impact e-sword all set to the
most heaviest of metals for music it's a
symphony of destruction and it's raining
blood on the 24th last up cat lateral
damage comes out on ps4 on the 22nd your
cat looking over stuff you're a jerk you
break stuff and you put your butt all up
in people's faces that's the cat way to
do and that's it for this week remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings sometimes they change I can't
help that I'll see you guys next week
Oh